what's up reject nation so this morning
a few hours trying to get that one
division video unblocked the second i
think i successfully did it made it
public
bam this came out and i was like no
that's cool
that's cool hard work for some
destruction
very common to be filled with are you
gonna cover this check out the godzilla
darn it so i hear this is like really
short i got a bit of godzilla and a bit
of a bunch of other hbo stuff in here
let's see what's in store people i'm
excited to check it out
godzilla got moved to march so that's uh
that's pretty exciting
so we're behind on an actual trailer
oh oh we're gonna slow that back
space jam that's what i'm hoping for
[Music]
suicide squad conjuring
the little things
show us a matrix dammit okay
available for 31 days from theatrical
release all right guys let's
let's take this back you know how we do
let's go
let's go by the frames here all right so
this this image has been cracking me up
because we got like two seconds forever
ago
and then we got two seconds a few months
ago and i did some like joke video that
really made a lot of people happy we've
been waiting
five years to get footage and we finally
have
two more seconds to add on to the
previous two seconds
that we got just be grateful
now we're getting an extra two seconds
right man
is this two seconds i gotta see if this
is two seconds this might be four
that's what i'm talking about just
release two
humongo here yeah they're battling
on a submarine at some naval security
craft carrier
what the hell did kong just was he like
was just decked out what boat what boat
was kong on
i don't know i know i know godzilla
obviously
swims was kong on damn look at that
thing
yeah you know maybe they were
transporting him again to put him in a
different show again
and then he broke out again i mean i
forget a lot that's a pretty sick image
this whole i mean this two seconds is
the other two seconds have been cool but
this is easily the coolest two seconds
i mean look at that bad boy oh damn that
is beautiful great shot
it's the battle of the century and i
mean it's nothing else at least
as every good godzilla movie must
promise there will be some
cool looking monster action save mothra
[Laughter]
you know we do i'm excited for it is
this mortal kombat right here just has
to be mortal kombat
no that's king kong sword yeah then and
this is the image that we got in mortal
kombat the other day but now we're okay
so yeah it is coming from his hand
that's what i'm talking about i was
saying how yes in yesterday's first look
how i was kind of getting like logan
reminiscent vibes of like maybe
it creates this like frostbite effect on
his hands maybe it actually hurts him to
use the power
you can see here on sub-zero when it's
coming through his hands
[Music]
i mean it looks mystical i i kind of
liked a little bit more if you
really pay attention to the hand i would
like it if it looked like it was kind of
like tearing through a little bit yeah
yeah
like it's literally like ripping out
from within
yeah because look at his hand his
fingertips i love a good gross
super maybe this is a little bit of the
body horror
element of sub-zero would have been a
little cool okay
so we got that what is this movie oh
this is the little things
uh yeah that was called yeah denzel
movie yeah
yeah yeah it's little things right here
we saw that trailer before he turns and
says what might be a spoiler
james gunn uh suicide squad or shovel
as deadshot if i'm not no i'm just
remember that space jam 2. this is what
i'm talking about baby
we got a cg 3d bugs bunny
confirmed so it's a 3d bugs bunny not 2d
let's look at this whole image back to
back okay okay wow
whoa who is j is that uh
what's the girl's name lola lola bunny
is she back is that king kong right
there
oh my god right here in the corner of
the corner
i mean i wouldn't put it past them to
put anything and everything they have
access to
tweety bird right here sweetie bird yeah
let's see
i think we see bugs at the bottom frame
looking up i don't recognize this hotel
it was an eiffel tower
yeah are they in vegas is this uh the
there's a there's a there's a i don't
know there's a paris hotel there's like
a new york new york there are hotels
that have things that look like actual
real world buildings but they said it
wasn't going to be the monstars again
so maybe they're someplace different i'm
trying to make out what his shirt says
[Music]
i don't know what is that bug's bunny
probably just says box bunny
yeah unless they have a new team name or
something like
this looks like a serious movie this is
the image
this image right here lebron it's gonna
be the who framed roger rabbit of looney
tunes basketball films
who is zipping up there i don't know it
looks
like is it is her name lola yeah yeah
lola bonnie
just don't ever call her doll and you'll
be fine and what is this this conjuring
three
me oh that that might be a good call i
mean it certainly looks
eerie and haunted house like she might
be the woman who was gone
because it's another one that's kind of
like exorcism of emily rose yeah they're
doing like a trial
kind of like true crime thing yeah maybe
this is a glimpse into her haunting or
her possession yeah
what's this will smith movie oh
goodness he's playing uh i don't
remember what it's called but he's
playing i think venus and serena
williams's father
oh and that must be venus and serena
williams yeah yeah i forgot what the
movie is called but i believe that's
what this is i'm actually not familiar
with what this one is
okay and what's this angelina jolie
movie uh
this is clint eastwood
just because people didn't see it back
when it came out and they're on the
beach that's mortal kombat that's mortal
kombat yeah
that's gotta be lou king right here
sonia blade yeah and that's got to be
our new main character
who everyone's excited for and is he
going to get back to his kid
that's johnny cage and um let's see here
judas and the black messiah is that what
this one is okay
and that's one of the ones about the
black panthers right i believe so yeah
yeah i didn't see the trailer uh tom and
jerry a new image of the suicide squad
[Music]
so those four at least make it part way
into the
first
oh look how they went with the goop i
was like i appreciate the editing of
this trailer yeah
because their guns are going down
they're like down here
they're letting those hands go plus it's
letto so you know you get that suicide
squad little link there
i don't know what this movie is i'm just
gonna
assume it's conjuring because of the
period hair
and then the immediate cut to patrick
wilson and vera farming
they're back in action tom and jerry
okay maybe we'll figure out what the
those some of those movies are okay one
of them might be in the h i don't know
it has to be in the heights yeah
i didn't see any many saints of newark
i'm not familiar with that one is
malignant malignant might have been the
one that we thought was the conjuring
that that
just looks like a horror movie title
cover yeah yeah yeah
king richard i think might be sure
damn no no images of the matrix what the
hell nothing
nothing teasing us by the way that
sitelock vpn that just popped up doesn't
really work for us guys
tried to access content do not access
content
okay all right well okay let's cut this
okay all right never mind we got some
information here so that image that we
thought was
that john incorrectly assumed this is
actually
the many sense in new work which is the
allen taylor directed movie
that uh is about a young tony soprano i
thought this was going to be a show
i thought he was working on a show that
oh no no no the uh
uh david chase is working on a series
that's within the sopranos world
that takes place in the past but it's
not about tony soprano i didn't realize
they were making a movie about tony
soprano oh wow that's surprising
yeah this is big shoes i just finished
the sopranos only a few months ago
for the first time and i've loved it and
the last two episodes haunted me so
i'm excited to see what's in the store
there i'm surprised david chase himself
is not directing that
this image right here as actually might
be uh james
wan's movie malignant which i mean
that's a very james
this looks like it looks like it could
be
in all fairness it looks like it could
be out of the conjuring yeah
and then taylor sheridan um i'm excited
to see what he
i'm always excited when his name is slap
thompson for something this is the
angelina jolie movie
they are not really re-releasing the
changeling i lied
a teenage murder witness finds himself
pursued by twin
assassins in the montana wilderness with
a survival expert tasked with protecting
him
and a force fighter what the hell that
sounds crazy
man that man versus the elements versus
assassins
jesus christ i'm excited i mean
sheridan makes intense stuff it makes
like intense
thrillers psychological thrillers and
this sounds like a crazy action movie
kinds of things where you feel like i
need to go take a shower take a walk
you know hug somebody after you're done
watching and then
cry macho is the clint eastwood one
which of course he directed he doesn't
start on anything that he's not
directing these days
nope well uh yeah it's all about space
jam 2 and that god delivers
i mean there's a lot to look forward to
um and okay
let's do this guys let's do this let's
all sign up for hbo max and stick around
glad i have an hbo max account
guys what'd you think of this godzilla
vs kong moments which moment stood out
to you the most was there anything that
surprised you here leave your thoughts
down below subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button and we'll catch y'all soon